et pour en parler nous sommes avec un
jean paul est mon médecin généraliste
président d'honneur de la fédération des
médecins de france bonsoir jean paul
eymond merci d'être avec nous kamel
boulhadid chef d'entreprise à la tête de
plusieurs franchises qui aimait les mots
l'indiqué en liaison avec nous par
téléphone en un homme qui soucie de ce
thème juste avant cette émission et puis
alexis poulain éditorialistes bonsoir
alexis et merci d'être avec nous en
direct également sur rt france emmanuel
macron qui va s'adresser aux français
une nouvelle fois demain poursuite du
confinement ou début du déconfinement ne
sais pas trop quoi dire qu'attendez-vous
de cette prise de parole quel message
docteur jean pas les mots moi je pense
que nous médecins on n'attend pas
grand-chose on attend surtout je pense
que ceux qui attendent ce sont les
petits commerçants ceux qui ont fait
beaucoup d'efforts pour justement que le
virus ne se transmettent pas qu'ils ont
du gel dans leurs boutiques qui ont qui
impose le masque qui prennent très peu
de clients à la fois
donc ces gens là attendent certainement
avec impatience que les commerces
puissent ouvrir puisque les fêtes de
noël approchent et et ils ont déjà eu
ils ont déjà vu à subir un premier
confinement est pour eux ça doit être
très dur
on aimerait bien aussi que le président
annonce que qu'ils permettent aux jeunes
aux jeunes scolaires aux adolescents et
aux enfants de de pouvoir reprendre les
compétitions sportives en plein air j'ai
vu que les championnats de judo s'était
déroulée je suis toujours un peu
surprise de devoir que le judo puisse se
dérouler ce heureux pour les judokas
mais je trouve que quand même là les
distances sont pas respectées
les gens n'ont pas de base qui sont
proches les uns des autres il y en a qui
font des immobilisations à terre et je
suis un petit peu surpris que cette
compétition puisse avoir lieu
alors que des enfants qui pourrait jouer
au foot en plein air ne peuvent pas le
faire donc tout ça c'est c'est un petit
peu dommage mais je pense sincèrement
qu'il faut tout simplement rappeler aux
français que malheureusement il faut
qu'on s'installe dans la durée et que si
on veut s'installer dans la durée et
éviter que cette épidémie ne se
développe il faut tout simplement
rappelé les mesures barrières le masque
la distance le lavage des mains et
malgré l'hiver qui s'approche
l'aération des pièces car ne pas oublier
que à l'intérieur des familles
la contamination se fait tout autant de
choses école qui prétend que dans les
lieux de travail
merci jean paul eymond emmanuel macron
qui s'exprime et justement dans le
journal du dimanche pierre vous parliez
docteur il ya quelques instants de la
cohérence écouter ce qu'on essaie
président de la république
rien n'est pire que l'incertitude et
l'impression d'une morosité sans fin il
faut de la cohérence de la clarté un cap
savoir ensemble nous allons et comment y
aller alexis poulain jean paul allamand
non le signal et il n'y avait pas de
toujours de la cohérence alors ce
deuxième confinement ni au premier
d'ailleurs il était temps de s'en rendre
compte la cohérence la clarté enfin je
ne sais pas si demain on aura droit à la
cohérence et et la clarté on ne l'a
jamais eu 1 depuis le mois de mars on a
eu l'impression
on a eu des mesures ubuesque à tel point
que la presse étrangère parler en
parlant de la france d' absurdistan
totalitaire et on à emmanuel macron qui
parlent de nous allons réussir ensemble
et qui décide seul
il s'est enfermé tout le week end à
l'elysée pour préparer cette allocution
de demain selon le jdd et puis ce
conseil de défense qui a petit à petit
remplacer le conseil des ministres
conseil de défense placées sous le sceau
du secret défense donc aucune
transparence pour savoir comment sont
pris ces décisions qui impliquent des
millions de français millions de
français qui se demande finalement
pourquoi cette crise à gérer de cette
façon là pourquoi cette crise sanitaire
est en train de devenir une crise
économique majeure
parce que confiné des confiné ne pas
donner effectivement d'horizon clair
pour les entreprises les aides qui ne
seront pas à la hauteur parce qu'elles
sont donnés sans distinction entre les
entreprises qui vont bien et celles qui
ne vont pas bien on apprend que danone
par exemple à distribuer des dividendes
a récupéré des aides et va pourtant
mettre plus de 1000 personnes sur le
carreau les plans sociaux vont se
multiplier et ses annonces eh bien elles
sont là uniquement pour temporiser sans
doute pour dire aux français ne vous
inquiétez pas vous allez pouvoir passer
noël en faisant attention
et puis on verra en janvier et en
janvier que se passera-t-il sans doute
1re confinement on peut se poser la
question des chiffres aussi qui s'affole
un ces derniers jours on se pose la
question de savoir si est ce que le
confinement a été utile ou non est ce
que le couvre-feu est il utile ou non
puisque les courbes se seraient déjà
inversée avant cela il ya beaucoup de
questions
en réalité sur la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire et puis il ya beaucoup de
questions sur ce virus le cnrs qui
continuent de se demander l'origine du
virus aujourd'hui toutes les hypothèses
sont sur la table
et pourtant ça mouline dans les big
pharmas les vaccins sont quasiment prêt
prêt à être mis sur le marché mais on ne
sait toujours pas d'où vient ce virus
alors c'est quand même étrange de voir
que nous sommes pendu a finalement à
l'allocution d'un chef d'état qui incite
par décret de vente ou non de sapins de
noël et qui demain je ne sais pas ce
qu'il va annoncer mais pour la clarté
il remplacera kamel boulhadid vous êtes
pendu justement suspendus aux lèvres de
chefs de d'état demain comme le dit
alexis poulain quel est votre état
d'esprit ce soir qu'est ce que vous
attendez mon état d'esprit je vais
revenir quand même sur quelque chose qui
est extrêmement important et qui remonte
du mois de mars
et on entend encore notre premier
ministre fin octobre qui nous dit que il
est irresponsable de laisser les
commerces ouverts et les entreprises
que ce soit dans la restauration ça soit
dans l'hôtellerie ça soit dans les
événements événementiel que ce soit nos
théâtres nos librairies nos petits
commerces
alors qui est vraiment irresponsable
d'avoir fermé des dizaines d'hôpitaux en
france qui est vraiment irresponsable
d'avoir laissé une situation dramatique
pour tous nos médecins nos infirmières
nous aide soignant avec des salaires aux
dbacks même en formation n'en ai plus
envie de venir travailler à l'hôpital
qui est vraiment responsable aujourd'hui
de la faillite programmée de centaines
de milliers d'entreprises en france que
ce soit des commerces que ce soit des
artisans que ce soit des
auto-entrepreneurs dans tous les
domaines et exactement d'accord qui est
vraiment et les responsables aujourd'hui
de la perte d'emploi de millions de
personnes en france
moi c'est la question que je me pose
quand le premier ministre ont dit c'est
irresponsable
mais toutes les responsabilités
aujourd'hui repose sur le dos de te nous
de nous deux chefs d'entreprise de
commerçants d'artisans d'employer des
gens aujourd'hui qu'ils ont fini leurs
études et qui ne savent et qui ne
peuvent pas trouver un travail qui est
et ricky responsable de cette situation
moi je leur pose la question quel qui
n'est ni responsable aujourd'hui dans
les grandes villes au moins cette date
est de voir des centaines de personnes
touchées des légumes des paquets de
gâteaux et aujourd'hui on interdit à nos
commerçants madame de perdus des
affaires et de leur autoriser huit
mètres carrés par client comment
pouvez-vous vivre en baissant votre
chiffre d'affaires de 100 % pendant ces
six derniers mois
est-ce que vous en étant journaliste est
ce que vous pouvez vivre sans salaire
pendant six mois
mettez vous à la place de ces centaines
de milliers de commerçants qui ont
investi dans leurs affaires et qui
aujourd'hui n'ont plus rien nous
n'aurons plus rien demain parce que ce
que nous disent nos gouvernants
concernant les aides de kells est dit
par madame il parle d'une dette sur de
la dette
exactement sac de quoi il parle qui va
payer les congés payés de nos salariés
ces deux jours et demi par mois par
salarié madame quand vous avez pas à $ 1
euro qui rentrent dans vos quêtes
comment vous faites pour payer les
congés payés de vos salariés
comment on fait pour payer vos dettes
bancaires auprès financier vos loyers
qui reprises
aujourd'hui dans notre infrastructure
d'entreprise entre battait 25 % de frais
généraux du droit comme en est
malheureusement kamel boulhadid je ne
suis pas fait pas encore partie du
gouvernement donc voilà je ne peux que
relayer ce soir voir votre parole avec
grand plaisir
d'ailleurs on va y revenir docteur amont
les chefs d'entreprise qui ont tous peur
de la faillite que duke au vide docteur
ça vous évoque quoi cette remarque parce
qu'on a souvent opposé on le fait encore
santé contre économie finalement ça
paraît compliqué de sortir de ce schéma
là aujourd'hui ça paraît effectivement
compliqué moi je serais pas aussi sévère
que vos deux interlocuteurs avec le avec
le gouvernement c'est vrai que j'ai pas
j'ai pas été tendre avec ce gouvernement
mais quand on voit ce qui se passe dans
les autres pays européens y compris dans
la grande russie on voit bien que les
gens sont sont confrontés à une épidémie
qu'on contrôle très mal et donc le
système tout à toute l'europe est touché
tout le monde est touché et on voit bien
que legault les gouvernements quels
qu'ils soient ont les plus grandes
difficultés à faire leur équilibre entre
la pandémie et l'économie on sait bien
on voit bien que
il fallait le confinement le couvre-feu
a fait de l'effet et on voit bien que là
on recommence à avoir quelque chose qui
est qui est supportable même si on est
encore loin des 5000 cas quotidiens qui
ferait que le système pourrait être
complètement à l' équilibre
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est pas
facile de gouverner en ce moment mais
honnêtement ils ont fait comme il
fallait
même si même si on peut effectivement à
s'énerver que ce soit à des médecins des
ip du biologiste qui prennent des
décisions qui qui reflète sur sur la vie
économique mais mais en même temps quand
on l'avait entendu monsieur delfraissy
le professeur delfraissy dire que le
gouvernement devait prendre des mesures
drastiques et qu'elle n'avait pas été
prise parce que le gouvernement essayait
de maintenir l'économie
on a bien vu que ça n'a pas empêché de
l'épidémie de redémarrer le premier
confinement avaient porté ses fruits
l'été l'été a permis de vérifier que le
virus circule est toujours s'il ya eu
une erreur de fait c'est dans l'absence
du nombre de tests au mois de septembre
qui nous aurait permis de contenir un
peu plus de tester et de tracer et
d'isoler rapidement les patients sera
peut-être été moins important si on
avait pu tester autant de personnes mais
surtout à avoir des résultats beaucoup
plus rapidement pour isoler les
personnes mais sincèrement qu'elle que
soit gouvernement d'où qu'il soit quel
que soit le pays
pour le moment il n'y a aucun aucun pays
qui s'en sort mieux que les autres la
suède qui s'en sortait mieux jusqu'ici
vient de recommencer à prendre des
mesures beaucoup plus drastiques qu'il
n'avait donc sincèrement je tapais pas
utile moi je taperai pas sur la sur la
politique et et franchement
dire que le président décide tout seul
ça m'épate un peu parce que je sais que
qui se fait conseiller à droite et à
gauche et plutôt deux fois qu'une kamel
boulhadid on l'appelle en avait environ
60 franchise dans le grand test des
marques prestigieuses on va pas les
citer ici aujourd'hui vous êtes tout de
même 1 12 gens quand même avec le
gouvernement on n'aurait pas pu faire
mieux qu est ce que vous lui demandez
concrètement on imagine que c'est très
compliqué pour vous aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui concrètement on a eu deux
aides
la première que toute la france a
bénéficié en tout cas tous les chefs
d'entreprise c'est le chômage partiel
concrètement heureusement que le
gouvernement a mis cette mesure en place
parce que je pense qu'en france il y
aurait 12 millions de chômeurs
concrètement donc c'est la protection
pour nos salariés et c'est bien que ça a
été fait à ce niveau là là j'ai aucun
souci avec ça et heureusement qu'ils ont
mis en place rapidement et qu'ils ont
mis ce degré de rénumération à 84%
je vais dire sans pourtant nickel y'a
pas de soucis le deuxième sur ce qu'ils
ont mis en place effectivement pour
aider des entreprises c'est le pge
mais le pedn mal à internet sur de la
dette d'accor cndd est à devenir qui bat
une tombée dessus dans les l'année
prochaine dans les deux trois quatre
années qui vont suivre et qu'on devra de
toute manière payés avec des intérêts et
le capital bien sûr restant dû d'accord
donc là c'est encore une fois un dead
qui bat que va devoir supporter bon
nombre de sociétés
il ya plein de société malheureusement
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne pourront pas
supporter cette dette sur la bête
d'accord la troisième chose qu'on ne
pourra pas supporter effectivement c'est
tout ce qui concerne nos frais généraux
faut savoir que dans les frais généraux
même si on a des reports de loyer même
sont à des reports de charges un moment
donné faudra passer à la caisse
il faudra payer et là le problème c'est
que ça fait six mois qu'on est en
activité sans activité imaginez-vous
malin l'accumulation de dettes que nous
avons de petites têtes qui viennent
s'accumuler comme dans un petit sac avec
et vous rajoutez à chaque fois une
pierre une pierre en pierre pour payer
cette dette à la sortie il faudra faire
entre 120 et 130 % de notre chiffre
d'affaires qu'on faisait avant postaux
vise avant la crise à caen si on n'a pas
réussi à le faire avant qui nous dit
aujourd'hui qu'on va pouvoir réussir à
le faire et c'est là où votre portage a
été très bien fait et la personne qui
ont parlé où il y aura une crise majeure
de toutes ces petites sociétés qui n'ont
pas les fonds propres pour pouvoir tenir
un tel et tel vague de de dettes qui
vont devoir malheureusement déposé le
bilan et la valorisation de leurs
affaires leurs vols la valorisation pour
ces braves gens qui travaillent depuis
des années pour construire leurs
retraites de demain elle bat tombé à
l'eau madame il n'y aura plus rien pour
eux alors je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec le docteur sur le fait que cette
fiche sanitaire sans précédent fait
qu'il ya de nombreuses personnes
malheureusement qui subissent cette
cette pandémie mais nous même ne sommes
pas responsables à 100% de tout ça t les
infrastructures du gouvernement avec les
décisions gouvernement qui ont fait
qu'aujourd'hui nos médecins nos hôpitaux
nos dernières ne peuvent pas suivre le
ce rythme là mais si on était
suffisamment organisés on aurait pu
réduire au maximum 7 cette cause
importante qu'on va tous subir et les
aides ne concerne pas non plus mal an
les congés payés de nos salariés qui
représentent 2,5 jours par mois
travaillé et aujourd'hui une société qui
a dix salariés qui permet depuis six
mois
elle accumule autant de congés payés
comment fait-elle pour payer cette dette
alex est un indic si pour la 1 re en
kata madame
boulaïd nous nous parle à nouveau de la
responsabilité du gouvernement jean
castex hier dans les colonnes du jdd et
rohff voilà s'est confié on a déconné
collectivement c'est un début tout de
même de mea culpa de la part du premier
ministre
jamais un coupable soit suivie d'actes
que nous entreprises tiennent à des
clips ou là où je voulais vous faire
réagir aussi parce que vous êtes 3
effectivement alexis pau là bas c'est
quand même moi j'ai l'impression que ce
gouvernement c'est un peu un médecin du
moyen-âge qui fait une saignée pour le
malade et qui est en train de tuer le
malade il faut savoir que 90 pour cent
de l'emploi c'est les pme et les petites
les tpe les très petites entreprises les
pme qui vont être signés par cette ce
choix d'avoir enfermé tout le monde
pendant des mois parce qu'il n'y avait
plus rien d'autre à faire c'était la
dernière solution parce qu'on a menti
sur les masques parce qu'ensuite on n'a
pas voulu essayer certains traitements
car il incombe dit il faut faire avec
leur md et dire vous allez voir ça va
être super leur md est dir est interdit
maintenant par le la santé mondiale en
disant que c'était un médicament
dangereux
finalement ce médicament et qu'il ne
sert à rien alors faire confiance je ne
sais pas par qui se fait conseiller
emmanuel macron et c'est bien tout le
problème qui conseille dans le conseil
de défense emmanuel macron et en dehors
du conseil de défense pour que des choix
aussi catastrophique soient faits les
uns après les autres les mensonges sur
les masques la fiasco des tests la
rentrée non organisée par jean michel
blanquer repris encore dans une
tourmente en ce moment sur un syndicat
lycéen mais reparlons de la façon dont
ce ministre n'a pas organisé la rentrée
en septembre
et aujourd'hui on fait payer la note aux
petits commerces au restaurant au bar
mais aussi à la culture tous les lieux
qui font le lien qui font que les
français les humains peuvent se
rassembler se retrouver sont fermés et
on est en train de tuer un pays non
seulement son économie mais ce qui fait
qu'on peut vivre ensemble alors on peut
le dire que c'est la faute au virus que
c'est la faute aux français qui n'ont
pas été qui n'ont pas obéi aux consignes
qui ont fait n'importe quoi pendant
l'été on leur a dit de faire ce qu'il
voulait c'était très bien l'été c'était
comme si on avait gagné cette guerre
contre le virus et pas du tout il était
toujours là sauf qu'ils n'attendaient
que la rentrée pour revenir on n'a pas
planifié
le gouvernement à continuer de fermer
des lits pendant l'été est plutôt que de
prévenir alors je ne dis pas qu'elle vit
évidemment il faut faire mieux formés et
des soignants et avoir délit et que même
si on en avait suffisamment
l'idée c'est que il faut éviter que les
gens attrapent ce virus bien entendu
mais le confinement c'est la dernière la
toute dernière des solutions est arrivé
à fermer les commerces de la façon dont
on l'a fait monsieur l'a très bien
rappelé les entreprises aujourd'hui si
elles sont aidées
elles ne seront pas aidés quand il va
falloir rembourser la dette quand il va
falloir arriver devant le banquier et
les banquiers vont les lâcher parce que
derrière la faillite des petites
entreprises c'est la faillite systémique
des banques qui est qui est en jeu et
les milliards du plan de relance
européen n'y changeront rien parce que
l'activité économique ne va pas
redémarré et ses millions d'emplois que
nous allons perdre parce que les
entreprises les petites entreprises vont
fermer la porte
on va pas les retrouver parce que
l'activité économique ne sera pas à la
hauteur
et là je crois que le gouvernement n'a
pas plan du tout à part peut-être de
faire des lois maintenant on en parle la
loi de sécurité globale pour préparer
une répression parce qu'il y aurait trop
de monde dans la rue mais le évidemment
quatremer 6 s attendent à un mouvement
social massif c'est l'évidence même
et malheureusement le gouvernement ne
fait rien pour contrecarrer et bien ce
qui est déjà écrit mal merci en tout cas
tous les trois d'avoir apporté votre
opinion et vos analyses en direct sur un
rt france merci à vous